hey guys so how's it going we got our
you reviewers Movie Awards nominations
on Monday as promised so how we're going
to do it in this video is I'm going to
do one category the schmoes are going to
do another we're going to go back and
forth like that last year we pretty much
did the same thing so you understand and
there's a little bit of news as to how
the you reviewers movie words it's going
to go down alright so the company that
owns deadline.com and movie line com
they're going to launch a YouTube
channel pretty soon here the YouTube
channel is going to be en TV and they
were like all right the you reviewers
Movie Awards I get it we get this we see
the vision as to where it's gonna go so
we're offering to host it on our Channel
entv probably paraphrasing as to how
they said it but it was something like
that i'm pretty sure so the you
reviewers movie awards is going to be
broadcast on the channel entv this frees
us up to do a few things we have a
larger range in a better budget we get
to bring you the best you reviewers
movie awards show that's possible as
we've all said from the beginning that's
always our goal and this year is going
to be pretty epic we have some really
cool stuff cooking up for you guys but
first let's get to the nominations and
keep in mind the you reviewers Movie
Awards is not like the jeremyjahns
Awards oh I think there will be a couple
things in a couple categories you guys
are going to be like wait dude what
about this it's how the people voted is
what the people wanted so that's how we
roll the first category is best
screenplay adapted or original and the
nominees are the descendants Midnight in
Paris Moneyball and the girl with the
dragon tattoo all right best animated
film that big fat Panda Kung Fu Panda to
the adorable kitten that stole my heart
Puss in Boots the really weird thing
lizardy guy Rango arthur christmas and
the adventures of tintin which more
people need to see no cars too oh
alright next up we got Best Visual
Effects why because when things blow up
people smile I guess it makes me smile
well I and the nominees are starting out
with things blowing up transformers 3
followed by Hugo then super 8 harry
potter and the deathly hallows part 2
and rise of the planet of the apes nice
alright best soundtrack to score there's
so many good ones that there's actually
six nominees because the votes were so
close whoo all right the first one
Hannah we got harry potter the deathly
hallows part 2 the Muppets the month is
really love the Muppets hominid cool and
then we have what else we go we got
warhorse I liked it coming up two years
in a row second
your viewer nomination what's the same
Nine Inch Nails out reznor and atticus
pitch for the girl with the dragon
tattoo and capping off the category is
Drive hmm all right this one is new to
the you reviewers movie awards show we
wanted to have a little bit more fun
with the categories this year so this is
the I'm shocked it didn't suck award
that's right in 2011 there were a few
movies that probably should have sucked
but they didn't they were cool and so
the people voted and they spoke and the
nominees are Thor followed by Footloose
Fast Five followed by mission impossible
ghost protocol following that is real
steel and then rise of the planet of the
apes why don't we always talk like this
alright another brand new category this
year this is best trailer and this now
is any trailer that was released in 2011
that was the question I had initially
was and again I love to 8th you're a
two-minute movie you have excitement
than I like you if you were released in
2011 you qualify alright best trailer
prometheus The Avengers the girl with
the dragon tattoo The Hobbit and The
Dark Knight Rises interesting to see
because the hobbit really got it under
the wire there right around the December
Show made its mark limited release
alright so the next category we got is
most underrated film these are the
movies that are good movies but in the
box office might not have gotten the
recognition they deserve and we start
this category off with Attack the Block
next up we got Hannah followed by
win-win then the adjustment bureau and
then one of my favorite movies of the
year warrior alright here's another
brand new category this year best hero
this could be best here open the best
anti hero it's anyone that really drove
the movie and did something monuments no
pun intended whoa coming in as a nominee
Cesar Moses not the Ten Commandments guy
they attack the block one gotta give
Harry Potter or nod you guys been
through hell and back I've heard of him
Ryan Gosling and drive this one I'm
really happy to see Rooney Mara Lisbeth
from it from the dragon tattoo and Mark
Ellis no I whoa oh no no one would know
alright so for every bed
hero out there there has to be a Best
Villain they might not be in the same
movies for these categories but now we
got the best villains of 2011 all right
so starting out we got Loki from Thor
will see you in the Avengers buddy maybe
got Kevin Bacon AKA Sebastian Shaw from
x-men first class bryce dallas howard
for the help because she played a [ __ ]
really well and Albert Brooks from drive
because he was a creepy bastard in that
movie finishing it up with Lord
Voldemort himself from harry potter and
the deathly hallows part 2 or Tom Riddle
I'm gonna call him tom riddle cuz no one
calls him tom riddle ok so breakthrough
actress these are the people whose new
who's the new kid on the block who's
going to be here to stay we've never
ever before we're taking a guest to see
who's going to be the breakthrough
actress Brit Marling for another earth
jessica chastain for our tree of life
right yes I'm gonna murder this poor
girl's name Bernice bae ho from the
artist fasho someone didn't take French
in high school I did not study let me
give you that name no reason why and
then oh of course you have to have a shy
Wayne Woodley who is the older daughter
in the descendants great job and
rounding it out Rooney Mara dragon
tattoo so every year you gotta give
props of the people who are like you
know what I'm kind of new to the game
but this is my breakthrough performance
and I'm here to stay these are the
breakthrough actors of 2011 we have joel
courtney from super8 than michael
fassbender from one of the four movies
he was in in 2011 pick one he's earned
it John boyega Moses from attack the
block and this is kind of weird for me I
me breakthrough actor Ryan Gosling from
drive it has the guy not been around for
a while but people voted for it so there
you go and John to suck at names Mark
Ellis help all right ready Jean Dujardin
oh thank you Mark I suck at names toldja
here we go best supporting actor which
one of these actors was great in there
supporting roles throughout the movie
first one I'm gonna say I think this guy
actually could have gotten the best
actor nod but I'm glad I got nominated
that's Andy Serkis for Rise of the
Planet of the Apes okay I'm happy the
guys on a list don't put it that way
another guy that I did really maybe
didn't expect to see on the list is
jonah hill until I saw Moneyball because
phenomenal and definitely are in this
time
well done here it wasn't for the sitter
Albert Brooks from dr he was absolutely
amazing ass movie well deserved
nomination good villain good supporting
actor absolutely for one of my favorite
movies of the year Christopher Plummer
from beginners and rounding it out Tommy
hey Nick Nolte with my hat on in warrior
that is your or so now we've got Best
Supporting Actress these are the people
who are like you know what let's steal
the show because that's what cool people
do probably wasn't their main motivation
but you know it worked out so here we go
we got Carey Mulligan from shame
followed by melissa mccarthy from
bridesmaids and then on to Elle Fanning
from super eight then shailene woodley
from the descendants and of course
Octavia Spencer for the help here the
bay twigs here the final final
categories of the you viewers awards
best actress these are women who have
been in movies this year Michelle
Williams for my week with marilyn Viola
Davis for the help emma stone from the
help oh really yeah Wow to help yeah
charlize theron from young adult and the
last but certainly not least Rooney Mara
girl with the dragon tattoo these ladies
were phenomenal in their roles nice to
see they're getting some recognition
from the you reviewers all right we're
getting down to it now we got Best Actor
of 2011 here are so starting out we have
Brad Pitt from Moneyball followed by
Michael Fassbender from x-men first
shame it's it's shame then George
Clooney from The Descendants followed by
Joseph gordon-levitt from fifty fifty
and killing it off with Ryan Gosling
from dr Best Director which one of the
directors took their material that they
had me just such a fantastic movie that
it became ons maybe a one of your best
list here the directors I made that
happen oh I gotta do pronounce this one
good lord I gotta said Nicolas Winding
repin know what's easy that's from dr
i'm talking about the guy who did the
artist uh have a Khattak Atticus someone
pronounce his name Jeremy you take this
category you guys are really asking for
my help i mispronounced marion cotillard
last name i probably mispronounced it
right there too and Killian Murphy's
first name note this is all on you guys
but I think it's housing a vicious I
think the rest of
then you also have David Fincher from
the girl the Dragon Tattoo mr. Steven
Spielberg war horse and then Martin
Scorsese what about I think it was that
was Hugo on your top 10 list and I'm on
but is a good move really good movie a
great director or so here it is guys we
have best picture and we have 10
nominations for 2011 because people
liked a lot of movies last year in any
case here we go we're going to start it
out with warrior and then go right to a
midnight in paris followed by the
descendants then making the list is hugo
followed by harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2 and then going straight
to the artist followed by the girl with
the dragon tattoo and then we have drive
and then rise of the planet of the apes
and then finally the last one on this
list 50 50 or so there you go guys those
are your nominations the votes are
coming in right now and then we will
have the you reviewers movie awards for
you guys next month and thanks to the
schmoes also for doing this with me we
got a lot of cool stuff planned for you
guys for the you reviewers movie awards
2012 it's gonna be awesome and here is a
fun little thing for you guys here we
wanted to a montage of you guys talking
about the you reviewers movie awards and
put it in the actual show so yeah if you
didn't already get your camera's out and
start talking about the you reviewers
movie awards and put a video on YouTube
now is a good time to do it tell us what
you're looking forward to this year who
do you want to win tell us what you
think about the you reviewers Movie
Awards we want to make a montage it'll
be cool and as always if you like it you
sing here and you want to see more click
right here to see more